Унікальність Більського городища саме в тому,
що воно єдине на теренах Європи, загалом, такої площі.
І таких масштабів городища просто не існує.
Зазвичай городища [становлять] п'ятдесят,
сто, триста, п'ятсот гектарів.
А тут — п'ять тисяч гектарів.
Тобто це найбільше городище на теренах Європи
доби раннього залізного віку.
Ну от, ніби уяву вражає,
але все одно це не усвідомлюється.
І не усвідомиться доти,
доки ти його не спробуєш практично.
Як кажуть археологи: «Щоб городище відчути,
треба його пішки пройти».
Хто не знає минулого,
той не може збагнути майбутне.
Ми намагаємося якось
все це розкрити, всі ці таємниці.
Як люблять казати: «Археолог — це як слідчий,
що потрапив на місце злочину через тисячу років».
Тобто в нас дуже фрагментована інформація.
І чим більше ми її отримуємо,
так би мовити, ми тим самим складаємо цей пазл.
Ніхто досі навіть не міг уявити, що під стінами
Більського городища може бути некрополь скіфів.
Тобто це люди, які мешкали на території сучасних
Дніпропетровської, Запорізької, Херсонської областей.
А вони опинилися тут — на півночі Полтавської області.
А це принципово змінює наші уявлення про те,
що ж тут відбувалось у IV столітті до нашої ери.
Активна життєдіяльність тут тривала
з VI по III століття до нашої ери.
Тут велася жвава торгівля з античними
містами-полісами північного Причорномор'я.
Вони туди постачали свою сировину,
яка цікавила греків і мешканців тих міст.
Дуже багато тут ми сьогодні в результаті
розкопок знаходимо античного імпорту,
уламків різних грецьких амфор.
Виявлені тут рештки багатьох майстерень:
бронзоливарних, гончарних, ткацьких.
Виявлені рештки жертовників, храмів.
Доброго дня!
Археологія — це, насправді (більшість з цим
погоджується), це не якась конкретна робота.
Це спосіб життя.
Якщо робочий день, він починається по-різному,
оскільки ми залежимо від погодних умов.
Якщо ми точно знаємо, що буде спека,
ми починаємо працювати максимально рано.
Але потім робиться перерва вдень.
Фактично, це сієста.
Всі обирають собі тіньочок і цілий день
сплять те, що недоспали зранку.
А ввечері після 17-18 години, коли вже сонце
не таке палюче, виходять на другу зміну.
Коли ми вже починаємо дослідження,
ми відкриваємо культурний шар частинами.
Оці культурні горизонти,
які відрізняються по кольору, по щільності,
відповідно, по часу формування,
ми розбираємо, звичайно, окремо.
Потім, щоб виявити об'єкти,
ми робимо так звані зачистки.
Ми повинні лопатою зрізати
тонкі пласти землі, щоб отримати зріз.
Потім всі ці знахідки забираються в табір.
Тут вони вже очищаються
від ґрунту різними способами.
Тобто камеральна обробка —
це ще один важливий пласт робіт.
Під час камеральної обробки ми все це замальовуємо.
Потім — фотографуємо всі знахідки і готуємо їх
для передачі до місця постійного зберігання.
Наприклад, у нас це — історико-культурний заповідник «Більськ».
Тут зберігаються артефакти з території
та найближчої округи Більського городища.
Колекція збирається з 1995 року.
Переважно тут артефакти скіфського часу.
Це частини від упряжі, від кінської упряжі.
Глиняна ліпна пластика,
власне місцева, місцевого виробництва.
Ось горнятка, такі ось горщички.
Скіфський меч акінак з бутарою
у вигляді голови хижого птаха.
Оце ми бачимо, оце ось, найдавніша тріщина.
Давнє пошкодження.
І щоб зберегти цю посудину (ось бачимо по колу),
вони проробили такі прокольчики і стягнули.
Тобто вони її зремонтували, вони дуже дбайливо
ставилися до таких виробів.
Це VI століття до нашої ери,
тобто архаїчний період...
існування Більського городища.
Загалом людям дуже цікаво.
Це все ж таки найбільше городище скіфського часу.
Одне з найбільших городищ, про яке згадував Геродот.
Так-от трапляється, що живемо поряд
і навіть не знаємо, що тут у нас за пам’ятка.
Я в школі, коли навчалася, взагалі не знала,
що тут є пам'ятка скіфської доби, що тут є таке велике городище.
Про скіфів взагалі такий малесенький шматок інформації був.
І ми думали, що вони [скіфи] десь там в степу були,
десь там біля Чорного моря, десь там в Криму.
Але аже ніяк не тут,
про це нам ніхто нічого не говорив.
Я через фейсбук дізналася, що в нас у Більську
є заповідник і що в нас є Більське городище.
І так склалися обставини...
Я взагалі любила й люблю дуже мандрувати.
Люблю досліджувати свій рідний край.
І також ділилася враженнями
про це все, робила пости у фейсбуку.
І директор заповідника це все побачив.
Він мені написав, просто запропонував:
«Чи не хочеш ти до нас у заповідник прийти?»
Я не була впевнена, чи я з цим впораюся, чи не впораюся,
що взагалі воно буде, як воно буде.
І мене наш головний зберігач завів у фонди,
показує мені, власне, чим ми займаємося.
Показує ці артефакти.
І я бачу цю чорнолисковану корчагу
з геометричним різним орнаментом.
Я дивлюся на неї, і в мене отак все в середині...
Мороз отак по шкірі [йде].
А я аж спітніла.
Я кажу: «Можна я до неї доторкнуся,
можна я так її легенько обійму?».
Якийсь такий от поклик, порив душевний був.
Він так засміявся і каже: «Ну добре, обережно підійди».
Я от-так обняла цю корчагу,
дивлюся на неї і не знаю...
Воно для мене от просто космос якийсь.
Якийсь отой далекий наш український космос.
З того моменту я навіть не сумнівалася,
чи тут мені бути, чи не тут.
Якось так воно все пішло-пішло-пішло...
Також я пішла в експедицію до Дениса Сергійовича Гречки.
Я пам'ятаю ці свої емоції, коли вже був вечір,
і ми розчищали дитяче поховання.
Вже дійшли ми до скелетика, вже я бачу і череп,
і хребет, вже кісточки оці добре видно.
І от якесь таке відчуття, знаєте, цей адреналін,
інтуїція, відчуття, що ось зараз щось буде.
І я раз — чую щось таке тверденьке
і розумію, що це не кістка.
А це був супутній інвентар, це була мушля каурі.
Це рідкісна прикраса на нашій території.
Радості моїй не було меж!
Це було моє, мабуть, найбільш емоційне,
найбільш потужне археологічне відкриття.
Я раділа як мала дитина!
І, от, це також такий переломний момент,
який багато чого змінює.
Коли ти його практично спробуєш,
спробуєш «смак» оцієї землі,
відчуєш на смак оцей весь процес занурення,
то дороги назад уже немає.
Багато археологів йдуть в науку,
вже коли навчаються в університеті.
І після першої археологічної практики
їм так все це подобається,
що вони надалі обирають собі цей шлях життя.
Але я обрав його трішечки раніше,
ще з 11 років, тобто це був п'ятий клас.
Я вже пішов на гурток археології.
І влітку поїхав сюди, на Більське городище,
вже в першу експедицію.
Часто питають: «А якщо я не археолог, то можна я приїду?»
Звичайно, у тому й сенс, щоб люди приїжджали,
долучалися до нашого, так би мовити,
руху, і воно працює.
У нашій експедиці достатньо спеціалістів,
щоб працювати фактично з кожним.
На сьогодні дуже багато є фейків,
дуже багато пересмикувань фактів.
Під Більськом знаходили вже й піраміди перегорнуті,
і це городище утворилося, як метеорит впав.
Тобто є такі абсолютно ненаукові, м'яко кажучи, гіпотези,
але частині людей подобається, чому ні.
Тому тут, мабуть, потрібно посилювати комунікацію
між професійними археологами та медійниками.
Професійні археологи намагаються постійно хоч щось,
якісь спростування постійно робити.
І тому, коли до нас приходять на екскурсії люди
чи просто питають, ми нікому не відмовляємо.
Ми, звичайно, розповідаємо, що ми досліджуємо.
І намагаємося їх якось зацікавити.
Фестиваль проходить у форматі «етно».
Ми запрошуємо українські музичні гурти,
які грають музику в стилі етно, фолк, етно-рок.
Паралельно з цим, ми запрошуємо майстрів з усієї України.
Створюємо таке наметове містечко майстрів.
І різьбярі, і гончарі, і ткацтво, і вишивка,
і витинанка, і ляльки-мотанки.
Ну дуже різноманітний спектр!
Також родзинкою нашого фестивалю є кінне шоу.
Цим ми хочемо показати, наголосити,
що скіфи були вправними кіннотниками.
Також запрошуємо реконструкторів із Запорізької області.
Вони повністю відтворюють скіфський одяг,
прикраси, певні речі побуту.
Якось у нас цей стереотип глибоко вкорінився,
що десь там є крута велична Троя.
Десь там ще якісь пам'ятки, Стоунхендж, піраміди.
А в нас... Ну що в нас в Україні, що там в нас є?
Не звикли ми своє цінувати.
А в нас тут під боком пам'ятка нічим не гірша,
ніж славнозвісна Троя, абсолютно нічим.
Наша культурна і археологічна спадщина
(культурна і передбачає археологічну) дуже багата.
Вона абсолютно нічим не поступається
здобуткам інших країн.
У нас перспективи — супер!
Коли ми зможемо хоча б на рівні
з сусідніми країнами, з Польщею, Словаччиною,
фінансувати археологічні дослідження, відповідно,
наші археологічні розробки ще більш тісно
будуть вплетені в канву всієї європейської археології.
Тобто люди з центральної Європи
побачать, що це той самий період,
будуть бачити, що аналізи такі ж, як і в них,
і можна буде їм порівнювати свої результати з нашими.
Це призведе до більш тісної, так би мовити, кооперації
і фактично інтеграції нашої вітчизняної археології
до загальноєвропейської та євроазійської.
Коли людина знає, що вона походить з цього місця
і пишається тим, що вона тут живе...
Наприклад, я живу в Більську,
я українець, я цим пишаюсь.
Мені здається, це той шлях,
який буде дуже корисним загалом для держави.
Я не кажу, що ми там....
Що ми найкращі.
Ми — українці. Ми маємо свої характерні риси нації.
Мені вони дуже подобаються.
Я хочу тут жити!
Я хочу робити цю країну сильнішою, красивішою,
створювати їй більш позитивний імідж, як я тільки можу.
І, загалом, намагаюсь зацікавити в цьому й інших людей.
Так би мовити, запалити в них таку саму ідею.
Оскільки, якщо ми тут живемо,
треба робити все в цьому напрямку, як на мене.